School fail you or you failed school
school failed me you know what's funny
yes and no in the past I would say yes
the school failed me but I also chose to
fail within that environment I think we
failed each other the good news is I
don't think it had an impact on either
you're being taught to play Within the
lines and there's nothing being taught
that maps to the entrepreneurial Market
but I will tell you that when you go
from 12 15 18 years of that ecosystem
and you go into a market and you create
an app the market responds to your
product and a lot of these kids have not
been able to take the punch in the mouth
that comes along with entrepreneurship